a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi dio sono fa vj e oggi siamo su
kart la teodem e prima di spiegarvi che
cos'è sta roba va lo sbatto fuori notare
una cosa ma quanto minchia può essere
ormai figo qualcosa allora ragazzi sta
certo ancora in versione demo quindi non
è ancora uscito gioco ufficiale soltanto
che è una cosa fantastica
non potevo non farlo la prima intese e
un gatto ed essendo un gatto devo fare
la cosa che sanno fare meglio i gatti
cioè buttare a terra le cose fantastico
prima i ragazzi questo può essere
considerato tipo un simulatore per
herbert disordinare la camera c'è una
nuova bellissima che poi il bello è che
spagna telecomando il suo gioco nave
questo questo non subliminale ragazzi di
ragazzi seguito anche giro sotto mentre
in piazza ci vediamo un prossimo i do
belle ragazze
vabbè non ha funzionato proprio così
però è andato giù lo stesso anche
ragazzi lo dello scopo li sto gioco è
qualcosa di meraviglioso poi il braccio
mi sembra tipo di volare questo braccio
proprio prova a fare il suo presente
bozzo qual è
ma che cazzo se non so ballare una sega
spera però tipo superman un salto così
se [ __ ] libri di scuola
questa fine che ci ha fatto fare ai
libri con è finito con definito l'anno
fantastica non capita ma c'è il tempo
cazzo portato al nuovo visto 0 troppo
eccitato dal comandare un gatto nero
visto il tempo fantastico
non sapevo ci fosse il tempo cazzo ma
via via il telecomando subito prima cosa
sono troppi cento dove cazzo non ci sono
neanche 100 oggetti st santana in
carriera di superman è il robottino che
avevo visto all'inizio
ecco è mica mia se il troppo un filo
stringermi la mano o cazzo
vabbè si può sempre dare la stretta di
mano bravo bravo perché colti amici come
prima simile ma che 36 ma [ __ ]
manca un minuto sul computer
loiero non so pensare quando tornano il
mio padrone di casa ai padroni di casa
che cazzo dice soprattutto giubbotto
affanculo toscana perché c'è uno
sgabuzzino con 14 scarpe questi si
buttano giù butta un gioco che va a fan
culo tutto ragazzo non ragazzo che sa
mai che avremo in quanto ordine non ce
la farò mai il quadro mai al dolcetto
secondi la pensava che la veloce insomma
non cade niente
si no [ __ ] [ __ ] solo qua non è
possibile da mezz'ora per buttare giù
tutto non è genio di piscio anche a
terra quello stronzo nel mio padrone
giuro
c'è una cosa che mi rendo la stanza uno
schifo procacciato qualcosa qui come si
fa a salire su sta roba
ma porca [ __ ] è che cazzo stata data da
dalt ad a ma [ __ ] non è possibile
si apre si sia brava però poi pensavo di
poter buttare giù tutto l'armadio ma mi
sa di no deciso ci tieni store maggiori
cuscini per che cazzo tiene dei cuscini
nell'armadio su deficiente fatemi capire
gli appendiabiti idee sono 400
appendiabiti se fossero stati sei
[ __ ] in più prima avrei vinto ma no
non è un caso che s'è fermato su 69
d'anna una gianna veloce ma che cazzo di
marco di televisione tre ragazzi giu
tutto ciò merda merda si tantissimo per
si si si 401 se lo fa non ci voglio
credere non è possibile
ringrazio dio è proprietario che ci ama
i film erotici sul comodino che sono
nomi ciao manco per il cazzo è stata
l'esperienza più brutta della mia vita
ma va bene così la gara ben due c'è
anche a vedere un 2 perfetto una carta
bella roba da buttar giù 3 cosa 30.000
master miss aprendo per il culo 30.000
oggetti non ha veramente 30.000 oggetti
volumi cozza è piaciuta a quello che
avevo 400 che come guadagnare un milione
di dollari vero che non abbia ancora
visto stati tutti perché mi spiace molto
no change no che sì co siting cube non
sta roba a noi che amica che fiducia
nintendo 64 fantasia via tutto trower
non generava ci gioco io una volta che
mi hai calcolato io vado soltanto
graffianti la faccia lurido pezzo di
merda come caccia fatta tornare indietro
al televisore ma scusate allora c'è un
telecomando costa televisore allora
accendiamo perché non è possibile è
ancora più il televisore giusto come
cazzo ti permetti di sbagliati sul più
bel nome è finito non avevo neanche
visto il tempo perfetto cioè mi conviene
dare un'occhiata più da vicino al
punteggio ma che sono finite nella merda
se time e un accordo ma fa ancora mi
viene da guardare il milan è da buttare
giù tutto come se non ci fosse un domani
le bacchette cinesi questo mangia sushi
nel tempo libero cioè non ho capito col
tuo televisore nel caso dovete morire
allora ci pensi due volte la prossima
volta invece di darmi da mangiare a
giocare video games trovate io li butto
giù tutto nel ducati corso a 25
a caso perché hanno fatto 41 mila in tre
secondi non è possibile perché
letteralmente buttato giù tutto quasi
forse gli manca più un assenso
e tutto a terra da donare a 43.000 c'è
un punteggio della madre non è possibile
che sia fatta fare punteggio 45.000 mio
debutto su pure la m le sette punti
cazzo rischio con tempi quanti pierich
ai per avere 47 paia di scarpe fammi
capire 48 scusatemi quest'anno lavoro
vizia perfetto altre console anche nel
magazine ma che palle
65 veloce lo fa ok meglio di così non
credo di poter far fatto più del doppio
64 mila forse 163 nei ragazzi ho fatto
un macello fatte salza 3.800 blair a noi
ragazzi io gli ho meglio di così non è
possibile la mia camera quando scatti
pacchi più più o meno e costi mandare
iva il mio padre li metto davanti a
tutto sto bordello e le dico tipo ne so
polizzi testa di minchia tuc ragazzi c'è
ancora l'inter box in nota in limits
nessun tipo limitati un gatto per sempre
a workshop perfetto quindi ragazzi e
dire che comunque se per qualcuno mi
farà una domanda un giorno in piani male
vorresti reincarnarsi io credo che di
scegliere il gatto fegato per fare sti
casini e poi basta che faccio la faccia
tenera e nessuno pensa che sia stato io
c'è la cosa bellissima
io non lo so pensare la reazione di mia
madre se vedesse una una camera così c'è
veramente non avrà idea ungheria sia
messa pasta si apre al cazzo lo sapete
quanta roba shirt o mio dio quanti cazzo
di preciso non lo sapevo io se usate st
rosa ma dovete dire piace anche la
stanza ma pesa l'assenza di prima ma
sono collegate le cose che cazzo ne so
io ma libero quindi ragazzi ancora il no
non aspettate terminati un pochissima
cosa troppo epica quello sarebbe il mio
padrone mi sa che gli cade la barba
quando vede che cazzo combinato ricorda
troppo una scena tenera che bei tempi e
dura che se potesse a sto tizio di
buttare giù anche l'armadio solo che mi
sa che non può che cosa c'è là sopra c'è
un altro robot sull'armadio che va bene
non importa ragazzi tanto penso di aver
fatto abbastanza casinò lug ragazzino io
e il gatto superman direi che possiamo
concludere qui l'episodio di ragazzi
servizio è piaciuto massei che lasciate
un commento mi piace scusatemi mi do a
grattare la zampa per cani gatti piace
fare ste cose anche la pagina di
facebook e come neri video trattare
speziale se non se ne vorresti di
splatter e ci vediamo il prossimo video
bella ragazzi